sírvase ver el video completo antes de
llevar a cabo el cuidado de su drenaje
este video le enseñará Cómo llevar a
cabo el cuidado de su drenaje quirúrgico
los drenajes quirúrgicos sirven para
extraer el líquido acumulado debajo de
su piel cerca del sitio de la cirugía
esto ayuda a evitar las infecciones y
favorece la
cicatrización un drenaje quirúrgico está
conformado por un tubo de drenaje que va
desde el sitio quirúrgico hasta una
perilla que recolecta el
líquido Usted debe desobstruir el tubo
de drenaje ejerciendo presión con sus
dedos para mantenerlo despejado y
retirar cualquier coágulo u obstrucción
a continuación vacíe la perilla cuando
esté medio llena o de acuerdo a las
instrucciones de su proveedor de
atención médica usted necesitará
toallitas impregnadas en alcohol una
taza de medir y una hoja de registro del
drenaje asegúrese de usar guantes
desechables si su proveedor de atención
médica así se lo
indica tenga cuidado de no tirar del
tubo usted no debe sentir un tirón en el
sitio donde el tubo entra en su
[Música]
piel paso uno lávese las manos con agua
y jabón y luego
séquel paso dos Póngase guantes
desechables si su proveedor de atención
médica así se lo
indica paso tres revise si hay coágulos
u obstrucciones que puedan impedir el
flujo del líquido fuera del tubo hacia
la perilla algunos coágulos pueden estar
escondidos dentro del tubo Bajo su
piel paso cuatro suelte los cuágulos
presionando suavemente el tubo que los
rodea paso cinco use una mano para
sostener el tubo de drenaje en el lugar
donde sale de la piel paso seis use su
otra mano para apretar el tubo con una
toallita impregnada en alcohol entre su
dedo índice y El
pulgar paso siete deslice los dedos
apretados a lo largo del tubo para
forzar el líquido a fluir fuera del tubo
hacia la perilla es posible que tenga
que repetir los pasos del cinco al si
varias veces para depurar el tubo trate
de no soltar el tubo entre los pasos si
hay algún líquido en el tubo o lo suelta
accidentalmente repita los pasos del cco
al Siete usando una toallita impregnada
en alcohol
[Música]
nueva no permita que la perilla se llene
a más de la mitad demasiado líquido en
la perilla reduce su capacidad de
extraer el líquido acumulado Bajo su
piel ahora debe empezar a vaciar la
perilla
paso ocho sostenga la perilla por debajo
de su incisión de tal manera que el
líquido fluya del tubo hacia la perilla
paso nueve dirija la perilla lejos de su
cuerpo nunca apriete la perilla antes de
quitarle la tapa paso 10 retire la tapa
nunca toque la abertura con sus manos
descubiertas paso 11 sostenga la taza de
medir debajo de la perilla paso 12 gire
la perilla hacia abajo y apriete el
líquido hacia la
[Música]
taza paso 13 después de extraer el
líquido siga apretando la perilla y use
una toallita impregnada en alcohol nueva
para limpiar la parte
superior paso 14 sin dejar de apretar la
perilla coloque la tapa en la parte
superior la perilla comprimida Crea una
succión que extrae de forma continua el
líquido Bajo su
piel paso 15 lea la cantidad de líquido
en la taza de
medir paso 16 anote la cantidad en su
hoja de
registro paso 17 vacíe y enjuague la
taza como se indica mantenga la perilla
debajo del nivel de su incisión para
ayudar a que el líquido fluya del tubo
hacia la
perilla comuníquese con su cirujano si
nota que la cantidad de líquido aumenta
o disminuye
repentinamente el olor del líquido
cambia el líquido contiene pus o se
espesa conforme pasa el
tiempo su tubo de drenaje se cae o se
abre la
incisión su incisión está rojiza
hinchada Es dolorosa o sale pus de ella
o si su temperatura es de 38 gr cel 101
gr Fahrenheit o
[Música]
más
y